un ténor 2002 on va revenir sur l'année
2002 avec tony et tout parce que voilà
je voudrais avoir été localisée photo ni
92 92 avec dix ans d'écart c'est fou
après ça fait 10 3
[Rires]
domine à ton âge oui non quand on
pratiquement oui mais
c'est dingue mais c'est fou on dirait
que enfin c'est fou
c'est là rien jamais rien pris dans la
gueule mais pourquoi est beaucoup plus
marquée
si vous vous rappelez quels étaient les
trois plus gros tubes en france en 2002
c'est quoi c'est quoi las ketchup
exactement a serré très
serré et des rennais
va débrider
[Applaudissements]
ouais y avait sa fenêtre qui change mais
ce que tu connaissais que tu auras tony
connais pas le cul ouais non à celle et
las ketchup c'était des triplés
c'est vrai quoi la même photo
chez la photo après la dépression que
c'était vraiment le dernier ketchup
a fait quoi de la planète et elle
essaierait bout mais bon c'est sympa
quand même voilà ça valse comprend les
photos les moins chers
je ne vous cache pas un lacet pas les
âges ketchup place et sait que c'est
compliqué pour alain y avait aussi les
l5 toutes les femmes
[Applaudissements]
le coloriage avait pas tu connais pas ça
non et jure c'est vrai elle cinq
obstacles je suis rien loupé la tête est
amoureux d'elle 5 avait dix ans pop star
le premier bout et tout récemment ouais
c'est ça la rue sainte croix qui est la
deuxième la deuxième à moins y avait eu
des prières sur mer avait présenté la
finale on va d'ailleurs excusez-moi bat
chip système ayant été dites moi
bakhouch
c'est quelque chose quand même à me dire
à quoi les laissez moi quelque chose
dont je parlais de tonner avant le
faisais moi ce que vous c'est normal
vous bossez c'est vrai rien à boire
c'est vrai c'est sur m6 d'ailleurs
confié à l'époque oui j'ai projeté de
finale non non mais oui post a présenté
oui c'est vrai
batum aujoulat
[Rires]
tempéré en 2002 il y avait ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
neil crawford dont on avait écouté de
bastos viens d'écouter le best of et
son best-of ça
va aussi alors les poches à celle là
la prochaine mini
baby microsoft qui avait eu une aventure
avec bel horizon
si tu l'utilisés le magazine fan2 bien
sûr
des trottoirs aussi away est lui-même
qui fait doux abondamment connaissez pas
bien et il m'a passé un grand animateur
aux philippines attendent des chiffres
et des lettres là-bas
2002 frappé c'est la coupe du monde au
japon et en corée fait à la mi-temps
d'un match de l'équipe de france les
commentateurs vedettes thierry roland et
jean michel larqué s'était embrouillé
pour une histoire de place il est à deux
doigts de finir en octobre au drapé ou
pas oui oui
oui l'année de naissance regarde ce qui
s'est passé j'ai réveillé l'azoté donner
gratuitement des gars de tf1 oui non pas
tant elles ont été donné il ya des
places partout derrière mme fabre a chié
attend toi aussi norbert dette à raison
tu as raison tu as raison ouais enfin
c'est l'écho une onde est un réseau
thierry qu'est ce que tu attends tu as
tord à 206 mois si je prend la défense
de laurent mais non mais je me branle
que tu prennes je sais que tu es drôle
du tout moi je sais qui tu es loin de
tout son blog non mais tu te mêles de
quoi je me mêle de ce qui me regarde et
non tu te mêles de tes jeunes y ont
certes mais ne m'a rien à voir avec toi
tu t'occupes de tes fesses tu es sur toi
c'était ça qui m'a donné l'envi
d'associer gilles verdez et isabelle
morizet il
ya peut-être un recul qui le foot sinon
tu fais quoi comme sport moi je fais je
faisais du tennis avant non c'est vrai
un peu j'ai un petit peu taquiner la
balle
j'ai un petit je suis dit et si tu
faisais des tourments patronne on n'a
pas joué comme ça comme ça quand il faut
loisirs qu'un bateau de bois voilà en
balle jaune j'adore tony tu fais
d'autres fort toi que le box pas du tout
va on peut pas un pop mais moi je suis
je suis né dans la boxe ça c'est vrai
mais le danger toujours fait que ça j'ai
voulu faire de sport je me suis dit
c'est dommage de ne pas avoir moins
essayer mais au final à temps et côté
bout dans un sport si nicolas pernikoff
qui changent tout le temps parce qu'il
arrive mal à trouver
ses repères moi c'est vrai car le
racisme était aux pads vous seriez pas
bien bateau ni à temps je joue avec lui
on faire massacrer un ouais je suis je
sur vous vous êtes vous êtes né dans le
badminton waseen ahmed minton mais
qu'est ce que tu fais à l'école on fait
sans
club non non c'est un vrai sport 20 km
heure l'euro de ce match est pour vous
parler c'est quoi
[Applaudissements]
enfin ce
compact de coupe du monde qui se
rappelle de l'analyse footballistique de
johnny au jt de tf1
en
2002 parce que vous les connaissez ces
joueurs de football j'en connais
quelques-uns bon bien sûr je connais je
connais j'agis bourget
je les adore comme joueur
l'ancien président jacques chirac
ils étaient ils connaissaient pas un
obstacle
la même année nous johnny nous en faire
une autre pépite j'suis pas su vous
rappelez leur la musique des bleus ouais
c'est
bien le seul
à mener lors de sa première
participation au paris dakar et lord a
perdu elle tape mon explication ah oui
la magie c'est l'explication on a tous
voila je me suis foulé le poignet dans
dans les dunes du ch et le bleu le blanc
c'est que tu te rends compte sur les pas
perdus une heure et quart on serait là
depuis leurs gardes
[Rires]
le magit ce qu'elle perde c'est aussi la
star ac' tu connaissais la star ac réf
non pas trop bâtonnier
moi je suis de cette génération
mais si sony de nous
c'est nikos sas académie ce soir en
exclusivité
alors qu'est-ce qui fait l'unanimité
anouk est philatélique
la suite en séries et si mon appel
c'était magnifique la star je regardais
pas du tout
la star ac c'était le seul télé crochet
pour lequel ont sélectionné les
candidats qui ne savait pas chanter
raphaël de georges alain rappeler est un
gros problème en espagnol justement sur
le tube sketch à céret
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
puis le magic qui les a
m
[Musique]
là bas
ap
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le début le stade mais ça a été un
flop épouvantable un autre a quitté fin
voulez vous voulez arrêter l'émission et
ça s'est joué à rien parce que france 2
a passé un match de rugby du coup enfin
des couleurs mais c'est ça s'est joué à
rien pour qu'ils arrêtent les bijoux
quatre semaines d'adaptation quand vous
avez besoin d'approcher les audiences et
que vous êtes sur tf1 vous êtes sûr que
france 2 va vous
devez y avait une autre émission qui me
titille l'île de la tentation
je connais rien moi en fait je connais
pas d'une
des deux tendances c'est très simple tu
as rêvé que ta meuf hockey et sans
revenus et donc il y avait des
tentateurs qui étaient là pour chiner
pour chébran ta meuf voilà et doit
traiter chacun sur une île toi et pour
ton mec qui a des meufs aussi qui est en
train de france et ont donc malin et
l'ontario ont sublimé donc tu es
tranquille sur ton île et y'a un mec tu
arrivé après le soir est comme un feu et
il filmait avec tout ce qui se passait
sur l'autre il était tranquille tu es
gens luttent à laisser ta meuf cerise
sur le cheese appuyer de façon je
connais je connais maï-maï balle bouge
pas une oreille
problème c'est que c'est pas l'heure
actuelle
à bâle à eva joly on n'avait pas besoin
de son oreille
et on va arriver et
tu voyais ta meuf été surpris des liens
directs montré
ses limites
le gars découvrez les images
ma la campagne jean luc la mer
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
hélas la main et me presse à jean luc
ettori alors qu'avez vous vu que
[Rires]
je devais maeva en train de
forniquer
avec marlon le tentateur non mais c'est
incroyable ça c'était extraordinaire
franchement je veux que ça revienne
l'île de la tentation on va faire comme
ça aujourd'hui ouais mais c'est dur
aujourd'hui sur quelques années mais
c'était plus soft donc ça marche chez
moi c'est sûr vous seriez bien ou
tentatrices
marie banos m'attendais pas mais ils ont
pensé à faire un senior ah oui sans
déconner c'est vrai nom mais je vous
jure que c'est vrai il est montré sur
une vieille télécoms arcep
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
projet quand même où
il n'a rien entendu c'est sûr
vous avez vu ça nulle en train de se
frotter avec ses libère